[Music]
[Applause]
paulie has a game here guess who took
the most threes team wise guess who took
the least amount of threes but that also
leads me to a question i have for nick
wright the popular co-host of first
things first on fox sports one
we'll play the game nick but also what
about this next year what if we had
a
no three point line
for one night in the nba like every game
there's no three pointers
we remove it just to see how the game is
played
oh i i like that idea i like the idea
that many of uh postulated which is make
the ark an actual arc so it would extend
out of bounds right so you wouldn't have
the corner threes anymore kurt
goldsberry had the single best idea
which is each team gets to draw the
three-point line where they want on
their own court like baseball teams do
with the fences so if you don't want to
have one you don't have one if you want
to have it at the ncaa line you have it
at the ncaa line if you want to have it
35 feet out because you're the hawks and
you have trey young and you're like
we're the only guy team that can hit
those i'm good with that i like those
ideas i really like the idea of turning
the three-point line into something like
uh a baseball stadium's outfield i think
that's a fun wrinkle okay uh paulie are
we gonna do most threes or at least
threes first
let's go with which nba team attempted
the most three-pointers per game in the
2021-22 season uh nick i'll let you
start you're the uh guest
oh in the regular season yeah
i'm gonna guess utah all right utah's
second oh that was gonna be my pick uh
seton
it feels kind of obvious so it must be
wrong but the warriors
yeah i thought
not them marv
did you say the hawks
oh
paulie no they're not even the top five
todd memphis
also not the top five can i say
something i'm sorry yeah where are the
warriors
does your crew watch sports no
okay yeah these are some bad guesses
boys the hawks are 18. is it is it the
rockets it's the minnesota timberwolves
number one 41 threes per game well you
do have carl anthony towns taking
six three-pointers a night
golden state is third yes oh third okay
yeah okay so the least
attempted threes okay there's a hint the
team took only 28 threes per game their
best player is known well no no no no
hints yet nick i'll start with you the
team that attempted well that that half
hint is now messing with my brain
i don't even
uh
so it's a it's a
not a hint it's it's just like the age
he was gonna say their best player is
known
for shooting threes yet they shot the
fewest
it's obvious
i was gonna say san antonio because
popovich was late to the game on the
three i don't know who shot the fewest
it would be a bad team i do know that
it's a bad team all right
uh todd you want to guess i'm gonna say
the rockets rockets rockets are fourth
for the most yeah i said yeah were you
just listening
i said rockets were one of my guesses
and i'm brilliant
satan
how about the
phoenix suns all right
sons are good decent guests they're
fifth from the bottom marv
talking about the heat
uh
[Music]
i'm gonna go the knicks
you're all very wrong the hint is their
best players known for not taking threes
oh
well that would be the heat with jimmy
butler or oh no it's the chicago bull
chicago bulls
yeah the only guy on that team that shot
threes was levine
all right let's talk about your
mavericks um yeah i i mentioned earlier
in the show that there are playoff
losses that are not equal like phoenix
you got to be disappointed if you're a
phoenix suns fan if you're a dallas fan
i mean you may be disappointed with last
night but there seems to be more hope
that you're building on something so
what do you think happens next for the
dallas mavericks
well listen i think this was a wildly
successful season but i also think they
have very tough choices which is they
might have to choose to take a slight
step back dan
because
i don't think jalen brunson is worth 28
million dollars a year if you if you
someone's gonna offer jalen four for a
hundred around there that's 25 million a
year for your crew that doesn't watch
basketball and i assume can't do basic
math but that's what it would be um the
sorry i'm taking a lot of shots here
guys my apologies it's friday i lost a
lot of money on this series how much did
you lose how much did you lose on the
maps
i mean
five grand
total you talking about last night or
total in the series total in this series
more than five less than ten however
it's what it's really the unrealized
games
i was looking at a smooth 72 000 dan if
the mavs
well it was going to be 72 if they won
the title it was going to be 38 if they
made the finals with a less than 3 000
total risk outlay okay so i mean it was
it was the unrealized gains i'm like you
know one of the many crypto folks that
feli feels like i was so close to being
rich and now i'm not uh but that's
neither here nor there so to answer your
question i wouldn't tie myself to jaylen
brunson as lucas co-star i don't think
he's good enough to be luca's co-star so
i think you might have to take a step
back keep flexibility until you find the
right co-star and so
when i picked the mavs on this show and
others to make the finals couple months
ago i said it's going to be like lebron
and o7 with that cavs team but if you
remember that cavs team never made the
finals they 08 09 2010 they had lebron
they couldn't find the right pieces they
never made the finals so that's team
wise individually
luca got banged on for his defense like
he wasn't trying
the lucas
below average defensively but it's not
for lack of effort
it is because he's not in good enough
shape and he and he does so much on
offense he rests on defense so he's 23
years old i understand the man likes
some beers and some hookah i get it who
which of us didn't at 23. but he's got
to get in better shape he should be
right now the second best player in
basketball he needs to get in better
shape so he can be better on that end of
the court
who is the second best player in
basketball
it might be luca giannis is clear number
one
steph is so impactful and he keeps
winning
i durant it's weird i
durant's better than steph but steph's
had a better career i think luke is the
second best player in the league but
i can't prove it but you don't want to
leave it to be true but i can't prove it
why do we always hesitate with steph
curry like like we we still don't want
to go
he's
he's in the top five or top three or
he's great
it feels like we we hesitate
maybe having a hard time defining his
greatness for some reason well i think
missing the playoffs and back-to-back
years you know in your early thirties
didn't help i mean that didn't adjust
the injuries they had injuries yeah but
last year he was there the first year he
had you know the world's worst hand
injury that wasn't the warriors tanking
at all because they knew they couldn't
win uh but last year you know and he
lost back-to-back playing games that
hurts him but i
and now i know that the new thing is
steps top 10. steph's top 10 all-time
top 10 all the time and i it's not an
outrageous statement the problem is in
order for steph to be in the top 10 you
must have a 12 person top 10. because
there's there there's simply
you
lebron crane michael magic wilt russell
you're at six
kobe
duncan bird you're at nine so for steph
to be in the top ten
he must be then be better than everyone
i haven't listed so that's better than
shaq that's better than akeem that's
better than dr j not to mention katie
giannis moses those guys so i listen i
think he's 12th i whether he wins this
title or not i i think it's going to be
a i think it's hard though he's going to
jump shaq
i don't know i don't think steph curry
is better than shaq i don't i think
steph curry's amazing i think he's
better than shaq i certainly don't think
he's better than akeem
yeah but it's tricky with these lists
because i think it has to start 1980 on
i i i think you have to do
you know the tv era i think you got to
be fair
to everybody involved here okay so so
listen it's very interesting you said
1980 on so on a very popular i don't
know if you've heard of it new podcast
called what's right with nick wright uh
they're doing this they're doing the 50
greatest players of the last 50 years
and it's a countdown 50 to one so it's
kareem to now i don't know you have to
start with the tv era i think kareem's
rookie year to now is fair because
that gets you cream that gets you dr j
that gets you rick berry get your elvin
hayes to now so if we were to do that
then steph curry's top 10. he's top 10
of the last 50 i think he's 10th but
he's 10 you know top 10 of the last 50.
i think that's fair when are you uh
doing your top 10 or have you done your
top 10 on that popular show not a
subscriber not a viewer on youtube not a
subscriber on the old itunes no i like
to just talk to you like tonight i'll
talk to you at dinner
oh you brought up dinner first oh
fancy that who lost that bet and guys in
the back but i didn't but uh but i
didn't lose a bet if i get to go to
dinner with you
oh that's it i meant who lost the bet on
if i was going to bring up dinner first
i meant a bet about the bet you we are
going to dinner yeah because you
foolishly picked the sun well i i just
did that for content nick that was
content oh okay no i wanted luca to win
no that's interesting i hope the
audience knows dan gives you takes for
content they're not what he truly
believes in his marriage
i wouldn't be the only host who does
that
well the only host i would associate
with tell you that right now um
but uh what was the question you would
ask me i had forgotten your top 10 on
your show oh when is it coming out so uh
players it comes out every sunday the we
are getting into the top 20. we're doing
i think 21 20 and 19 this sunday early
and then next sunday you know so on so
forth we'll do three per day until we
get to the top ten so over the next few
weeks uh the joker has reaffirmed his
long-term commitment to denver
clearing the way to sign a 260 million
dollar super max in the off season that
according to shams
that makes sense
has anyone ever turned down the super
max on their first real bite at the
massive money apple i mean no of course
and they're a good team and with the
jamal murray is good maybe a touch
overrated but good and michael porter jr
if healthy could be
their their hope is this
that michael porter jr can be the second
best player jamal murray if he's your
third best player you can win a title
but the question is michael porter jr
and his health and his back all that's
very concerning but they are now going
to be locked that's their team joker's
going to be making 50 million they paid
porter jr early when they didn't need to
when the questions were about us back
he's making 30 and i think jamal's
making about 30. that's probably why
they didn't have the money to pay their
gm the gm left he's like yeah you got
money for the players got they don't got
money for me i found the player so he's
out of there but yeah they'll be i mean
they'll be good i don't think they'll
win the title
explain the celtics turn around in
mid-january
i can't
it's
udoka credit to him
credit to
smart tatum and brown
for staying together for not because do
you remember marcus smart had that odd
quote
where he was like essentially it was
jason tatum needs to pass the ball more
yeah
it's marcus smart's time to cook
and
that could have ripped a team apart
credited him for a good trade deadline
move credit to brad stevens
for attaching a pick to kimball walker
to bring in al horford a move that i
didn't totally understand like al
horford but al horford has been
invaluable to them they've developed
their players well robert williams has
been healthy he's been excellent i
didn't see this one coming at all now
don't put it past the celtics to blow a
3-2 lead in the conference finals they
love doing that however usually lebron's
the reason for it if the celtics you
know how they named all these trophies
you have the larry bird trophy now the
magic johnson trophy and bob cousy if
the celtics lose they end up losing this
conference finals but i don't think they
will do you think they'll name the
eastern conference runner-up trophy
after the celtics wow because they keep
getting it wow that's a shot yeah sorry
i'm not a fan the celtic fans man
do you think jordan is bothered that he
got left out
so isn't that interesting so i was
thinking i was like three greatest
players ever
lebron kareem and jordan none of them
got anything named after him but then i
was like no kareem has the social
justice award named after him
so lebron and jordan not having anything
named after him
feels odd to me i also felt like
eastern conference mvp eastern
conference mvp and western conference
mvp
should have been
kobe and lebron
i i was surprised maybe they didn't want
to give it to an active player it felt
like that was a weird because the the
mvp
they gave it to
koozie and was it elgin
lg was in the western government's
finals three times i think you only won
it twice like i i love elgin but it was
an odd choice there and kuzy's fine i'm
sure it made mad dog happy but i i would
have thought it should have been lebron
and kobe for those two
i like chris broussard's take though on
koozie and
that that he was sticking up for the old
school basketball player
um you know j.j reddick called out mad
dog russo and said that that basically
bob kuzie was playing against what
firemen and policemen or whatever
plumbers or whatever
here's what i believe
i believe that both of these things can
be true
i truly believe that if you took bob
cousy in his form at his apex of
basketball and dropped him into today's
nba or today today's world
he could not get a division 1
scholarship i believe that i also
believe
he's one of the 30 greatest players ever
just like
jesse owens could not qualify
for the finals of the latest ncaa
championships but he might be the
greatest track and field athlete ever or
certainly one of the greatest both of
those things can be true and it's what
to me it's
it's unfair be like so j.r smith
is better than the majority of people
bob cousy played against but that
doesn't mean jr smith's better than bob
cousy like i just don't think it's fair
to to analyze things that way you can
only compete against the your era and so
i yeah i think jj was half right on
koozie but also way wrong i'll leave you
with this you can sign one of the two
long term
james harden or kyrie irving kyrie
because kyrie is still very good he's
just a pain in the ass and he's
unreliable
i don't know if harden's good anymore
like i'd rather
i'd rather deal with it's like someone's
like hey
who do you want they're both free agents
who do you want to sign to a long-term
broadcasting deal nick wright uber
talented but a bit of a x-fa like a wild
card
not that reliable kind of a pain in the
ass to work with or dan patrick clearly
passed this problem like we were like
who what are you going to do in that
spot and neither is great but i think
people probably like ah give me the
young talent that's a hypothetical
though right well i'm not a free agent
anytime soon i don't know about you
but past his prime thing i mean
are you still a good actor
yeah
well according to your wife
no she said you were good looking oh
not past my prime there
okay
no that's a weird thing you're better
looking now i don't mind complimenting
your looks you're an objectively
handsome man just like you're
objectively used to be a better
broadcaster okay and now you've got
these guys telling you the houston
rockets don't you threes
i mean it's not i mean you can only
carry this squad so far that's what's
amazing i'm doing what lebron did with
the cavaliers you know what you know
what not the 07 caps with the 2018 caps
also an older lebron people question was
he past his prime then it's like could
anyone else have taken these guys this
far you know what i take it back okay
excited to see you dinner tonight by the
way uh i just don't want to overdress or
underdress because last time you came in
with uh a full length red
you know coat i was wearing you look
like lenny kravitz you look like lenny
kravitz i was wearing a nice coat it was
chilly out i i i am leaving dinner and
driving straight to a casino in
philadelphia so i'm going to be dressed
in gambling attire so there's going to
be a little jewelry you're seeing i'm
wearing some of it now already there's
going to be a lot of cash in my pocket
and you know some nice jeans sh nice
shoes and ready to roll man ready and
i'm picking up the time
damn straight yeah and i and you're
taking me to a mutton chop house i said
a wagyu beef and you're like hey where's
some sheep we can get
uh i look forward to having breaking
bread with you tonight you too i can go
earlier too i know you know i know guys
your age they tend to they want to get
we're going at six o'clock that's that's
early enough
that's early enough all right talk to
you then that's uh nick wright first
things first